les publicains apporte son soutien à
renaud muselier en l'absence est
d'accord avec la république en marche
déclarations de christian jacob à
l'issue de la commission d'investiture
qui s'est tenu ici ce soit au siège du
parti je vous propose d'écouter le
patron des républicains
c'est un accord d'une famille rassemblée
qui a été secoué
mais rassembler aujourd'hui avec renaud
muselier et les républicains qui sortent
renforcés de cette de cette ceni puisque
l'accord est quasi quasi unanime à
quelques voix près la république en
marche a démontré sa faiblesse la
faiblesse on la connaît ils sont
incapables de constituer une liste
incapables de porter un projet
alternatif uniquement capables de
manoeuvre et de nuisances et le premier
ministre était clairement renvoyé dans
ses cordes
après les déclarations qu'il avait pu
faire dimanche dernier donc c'est une
belle victoire mais surtout ça nous met
en situation de gagner les régionales
est ce qu était déterminant pour
été déterminant pour nous renaud
muselier et sa majorité bénéficie d'un
bilan remarquable
il est souligné par tous voilà pour ce
tacle envers la république en marche
christian jacob il avait déjà exprimé un
petit peu plus tôt c'est au brouillage
traduire pour lui l'incapacité pour
aller rem de conduire une liste dans la
région un pas car du côté de la
république en marche et bien à gabriel
attal affirme lui ce soir qu'il y aura
bien sûr des candidats lrm sur la liste
de renaud muselier mais christian jacob
a été très clair en ce soir pas de
parlementaires pas de mine east je vous
rappelle que tout ce remue ménage est
partie de l' annonce de jean castex
dimanche le premier ministre qui a fait
part du retrait de la liste lrm dans la
région apac à au profit de la liste
conduite par renaud muselier le
principal intéressé qui là aussi un
petit peu plus tôt réaffirmé 1
il n'y a dans un communiqué il n'y a pas
et il n'y aura pas d'accord à quelques
niveaux que ce soit avec en marche pas
plus qu'avec d'autres appareils fin de
citation